la fage là c'est pour tout ça là ces
dépôts partout ce n'est pas un salon de
coiffure ordinaire mais un centre anti
poux le concept vient des états unis et
connaît un grand succès en espagne
depuis deux ans ces centres arrivent en
france celui de mantes-la-jolie a ses
propres méthodes c'est le premier en
yvelines on travaille avec aucun produit
chimique ont fait travailler un petit
fabricant et récoltant d'hydrolats et
d'huile qui se situe dans la drôme des
produits 100% naturels et bio est une
méthode artisanale
les clients restent le temps qu'il faut
pour s'assurer d'être entièrement
débarrasser une fois qu'on a retiré le
surplus des poux et les lentes on va
aller rechercher toutes les lans
restantes sur chaque cheveu et de
retirer à la main une par une ciao nice
a ouvert en mai dernier et a pour
objectif de se développer sous forme de
franchise la demande est là un pou
femelle peut pondre jusqu'à 10 l'an par
jour et déclenché l'invasion
c'est pas du tout une question d'hygiène
c'est un animal qui est notre compagnon
depuis toujours et c'est
même titre que linguistique par exemple
ça fait partie de notre quotidien
en plus du traitement le centre n'oublie
pas de prodiguer des conseils pour ne
jamais voir revenir ses clients je lis à
repart avec le sourire cela faisait un
nom qu'elle essayait de s'en débarrasser
je n'avais j'en ai plus et après on
affine kit net
compter entre 30 et 60 14 euros selon la
longueur des cheveux pour un traitement
en une fois et un contrôle la semaine
suivante